Hi there, it's Marianne here. Before we dive into today's episode, I want to quickly let you know about something exciting that's happening right now. If you've ever wondered how to create income that works for you, rather than constantly trading your time for money, then you'll love the Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge with my business mentor, Lisa Johnson. This challenge is designed to help you build sustainable income streams. And whether you're an aspiring psychologist, a mental health professional, or in a completely different field,
大家好，我是玛丽安（Marianne）。在深入今天的节目之前，我想快速和大家分享一件目前正在发生、让人兴奋的事情。如果你曾想过如何创造属于你的被动收入，而不是没完没了地用时间去换取金钱，那你一定会喜欢由我的商业导师丽莎·约翰逊（Lisa Johnson）发起的“向持续性收入冲刺挑战”（Race to Recurring Revenue Challenge）。这个挑战旨在帮你建立可持续的收入来源。无论你是有志成为心理学家的人、心理健康专业人士，还是身处完全不同的领域，
the principles can work for you. There are also wonderful prizes to be won directly by Lisa herself. And if you join the challenge by my link, you can be in with a chance of winning a one-to-one hours coaching with me, Dr. Marianne Trent. Do you want to know more? Of course you do. Head to my link tree, Dr. Marianne Trent, or check out my social media channels, or send me a quick DM and I'll get you all the details. Right, let's get on with today's episode. Coming up in today's episode, I am joined by Dr. Mari Covenant, who is a counselling
这些原则都对你适用。此外，还有由丽莎亲自送出的丰厚奖品等你来拿。如果你通过我的链接加入挑战，你将有机会赢得与我——玛丽安·特伦特博士（Dr. Marianne Trent）进行一对一小时指导的机会。你想了解更多吗？你当然想。前往我的 Linktree（Dr Marianne Trent），查看我的社交媒体渠道，或者给我发个简短的私信，我会把所有详情发给你。好了，让我们进入今天的节目。在今天的节目中，我邀请到了心理咨询
psychologist. We are discussing her route to becoming qualified, as well as her background being Finnish. We also talk about the unique quandary of trying to date when you are a psychologist and a mental health professional hope you find this so useful if you're looking to become a psychologist then let this be your guide with this podcast that's your side to be on your way to being qualified. It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast with Dr. Marianne Trent. Hi, welcome along to the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast.
心理学家玛丽·科文南博士（Dr. Mari Covenant）。我们将讨论她成为合资格心理学家的历程，以及她作为芬兰人的背景。我们还将探讨当你作为一名心理学家和心理健康专业人士时，试图约会所面临的独特困境。如果你正想成为一名心理学家，希望你能觉得这期节目非常有用，并让它成为你的指南，伴你踏上获得专业资质的旅程。这里是《有志心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是玛丽安·特伦特博士。嗨，欢迎来到《有志心理学家播客》。
I am Dr. Marianne Trent and I am a qualified clinical psychologist. Now in order to become a clinical psychologist, I had to go through the rigmarole and sometimes what felt like the personal exquisite torture of going through the clearinghouse system to apply by filling in a form. If this is your reality right now, or if you're filling in forensic psychology forms or educational psychology forms, and you would welcome some additional support, please check out my replay Q&A sessions, which are called compassionate Q&As because they're so nurturing and gentle and helpful, which you can find by going to my YouTube channel, Dr. Marianne Trent.
我是玛丽安·特伦特博士，我是一名合资格的临床心理学家。为了成为一名临床心理学家，我曾不得不经历繁文缛节，有时甚至感觉像是通过填表来申请的清算所（clearinghouse）系统，那真是一场精细的个人折磨。如果这也是你目前的现实，或者如果你正在填写法医心理学或教育心理学申请表，并且希望得到一些额外的支持，请查看我的回放问答环节，它们被称为“同理心问答”（compassionate Q&As），因为它们非常具有滋养性、温和且有帮助。你可以在我的 YouTube 频道“Dr. Marianne Trent”上找到它们。
If you'd like a little bit more looking for the next level, looking for the next way to work with me, then do please consider coming on board to the Aspiring Psychologist membership, where the members say really great things about how helpful our work is and what we offer in helping them with their goals. I love that some of the connections we will make along the way are useful for us as part of our process, but also for the things we learn along the way too. It's my absolute pleasure to meet somebody today for the podcast who I've known about socially on social media for the last few years, but today is the first time we have met. I'm so excited to introduce you to her, hope that you'll get a lot of useful information from it. Here's another
如果你想要更多支持，寻找下一个层级，或者寻找与我合作的新方式，那么请考虑加入“有志心理学家会员计划”（Aspiring Psychologist membership）。我们的会员对我们的工作有多大帮助以及我们在实现他们目标方面所提供的支持给予了极高的评价。我非常喜欢我们在这一路建立的一些联系，它们不仅对我们的成长过程有用，对我们一路学到的东西也很有帮助。今天我非常高兴能在播客中采访这样一位嘉宾：过去几年我在社交媒体上就知道她，但今天是我们的初次见面。我很高兴向大家介绍她，希望你能从中获得很多有用的信息。接下来这
one where you might learn a lot about culture, specifically Finnish culture, but also about a different psychology discipline. In fact, two different psychology disciplines that don't get so much airtime in this podcast. I hope you'll find it really interesting and you might also learn some tips for how to date successfully too. Hope you find it useful. I hope you'll find it really interesting and you might also learn some tips for how to date successfully too. Hope you find it useful. I look forward to catching you on the other side. Hi, just want to welcome our guest for today, Dr. Mari Covenan. Hi, Mari. Hi, lovely to be here and thank you, Marianne, for inviting me. Oh, well, thank you for saying yes. So we have been in each other's world for quite a few years now.
期节目中，你可能会学到很多关于文化的知识，特别是芬兰文化，还有关于一个不同的心理学流派的知识。事实上，是两个在这个播客中不常被提及的不同心理学流派。我希望你会觉得非常有趣，你可能也会学到一些如何成功约会的小贴士。希望你觉得有用。我希望你会觉得非常有趣，你可能也会学到一些如何成功约会的小贴士。希望你觉得有用。期待在节目后半部分与你相见。嗨，我只想欢迎今天的嘉宾玛丽·科文南博士。嗨，玛丽。嗨，很高兴来到这里，谢谢玛丽安邀请我。哦，谢谢你答应。所以我们进入彼此的世界已经好几年了。
This is the first time we've ever spoken to face to face, which is exciting. So we are both part of a psychology network and you are, I'm right in in saying a qualified counselling psychologist yes lovely and also from our chats in setting up this podcast I understand you've done some occupational psychology as well yes that was in my past yeah is that something that still informs your practice now um well I suppose when therapy clients come to me often um they are obviously work related situations so it's quite a good background to know and talk to people about the situations but it's um i realized when i worked i did selection recruitment and it didn't hit those spots that I really wanted. I wanted much deeper connection and being able to help people really on a much deeper level.
这是我们第一次面对面交谈，这让人兴奋。所以我们都属于一个心理学网络，我说得没错吧，你是一名合资格的心理咨询心理学家，对吗？是的，太好了。而且根据我们筹备这个播客时的聊天，我了解到你还做过职业心理学，对吗？是的，那是在我的过去，是的。那现在仍然对你的实践有指导意义吗？嗯，我想当治疗客户来找我时，通常……他们显然会有与工作相关的情况，所以了解这些背景并与人们谈论这些情况是挺不错的，但是……我意识到，当我从事选择和招聘工作时，它并没有触及我真正想要的点。我想要更深度的连接，能够真正以更深层次去帮助人们。
So, yeah, I moved on from that. But I guess, you know, whatever you ever learn, you will never forget. So in some ways, I love that. I've never I've never heard that phrase before I really like that but um it isn't actually something we've spoken about in the podcast so far for those that are listening that might not know what it involves could you briefly guide us through what occupational psychology is okay so um it is really everything to do with human and work. So it is really starts from something even basics like, you know, thinking about usability of things.
所以，是的，我从那份工作转行了。但我想，你知道，无论你学过什么，你永远都不会忘记。所以在某种程度上，我喜欢这样。我从没听过这个短语，我真的很喜欢。但是……这其实并不是我们之前在播客中谈论过的话题。对于那些可能不知道它涉及什么的听众，你能简要带我们了解一下什么是职业心理学吗？好的，嗯……它其实关乎人类与工作的一切。所以它确实从一些最基础的事情开始，比如，思考事物的可用性。
You know how I don't know. I've got this microphone in front of me. And how usable is it for for me me for example how it works so you know it's it covers so many things and then going into work well-being organizational changes and you know leading that kind of changes and so it covers so many from the individual level really to bigger kind of more social sort of organizational um things and um yes and so I I did um I did selection I did career counseling coaching this was a bit so originally I'm from Finland and then we spoke a little bit before this that I started my training here and then I moved to Finland and I moved to work in a job centre in Finland. And all the job centres in Finland got psychologists in them who are helping people with their careers and career changes or finding your first career. And so on. This was even set up like after the war because they wanted really, I guess, make best use of the workforce. And yeah, now I was doing selection, but also helping people with their careers and thinking about careers and all of that kind of stuff so there are so many
你知道，我不知道，我面前放着这个麦克风。例如，对我而言它的可用性如何，它是如何运作的……所以它涵盖了许多方面，然后深入到工作福祉、组织变革以及（你知道的）领导这类变革，因此它涵盖了非常广泛的层面，从真正意义上的个体层面到更大、更具社交性和组织性的层面……是的，所以我曾从事过……我做过筛选、职业咨询、教练工作。这有点……我最初来自芬兰，我们之前稍微聊过，我在英国开始培训，然后我搬到了芬兰，并在芬兰的一个就业中心工作。芬兰所有的就业中心都有心理学家，他们帮助人们规划职业和职业转换，或者找到第一份职业等等。这甚至是在战后建立的，因为他们真的希望（我想）充分利用劳动力。是的，当时我既做筛选，也帮助人们规划职业、思考职业以及所有这些相关的事情，所以职业心理学有非常多
different really areas to occupational psychology and if anyone is really interested in you know whether it's work well-being or all of these kind of things it's it's a really good option thank you and i just love learning about things and learning about people and I did not know that about Finland that they've got psychologists in their job offices that sounds like such well it makes sense doesn't it but it sounds like such a great idea yeah absolutely brilliant but so you're a counselling psychologist um a chartered one as well, which for those who are listening means that you are registered with the British Psychological Society. But of course, what we know about counselling psychologists is that it's a protected title. So you'll also need to be
不同的真正领域，如果有人真的很感兴趣（无论是工作福祉还是所有这些事情），这真的是一个很好的选择。谢谢你，我就是喜欢了解事物和了解人，我以前并不知道芬兰的就业办公室里有心理学家，听起来……这很有道理，对吧？但听起来真是一个好主意。是的，绝对太棒了。所以你是一名心理咨询心理学家……还是一位特许（Chartered）心理学家，对于听众来说，这意味着你在英国心理学会（BPS）注册了。当然，我们所知道的是，心理咨询心理学家是一个受保护的头衔。所以你还需要在
registered with the HCPC too. Yes, yes, absolutely. Lovely. Thank you very much for that. Whilst we're discussing the HCPC, I don't know if you find this as well, but when they take their subs out from me, I think it's a few times a year, they seem to just take it, but they do not send me an invoice. They do not send me a receipt. And I'm like, how am I going to square that with my accountant? Like like where do I go with that yeah no it's it's like a bit of a secret society in some ways and you hear maybe a couple emails come once in a blue moon but there's not much communication with them and I think that's why I've stayed with the BPS is because um I guess I felt well well I'll tell you what when I was in Finland for that about five year period or so, the Finnish equivalent, that society, the psychological society became really like a place, you know, it's almost like a family.
HCPC（健康与护理专业委员会）注册。是的，是的，绝对的。太好了，非常感谢。既然我们在讨论 HCPC，我不知道你是否也有同感：当他们从我这里扣除会费时——我想一年有好几次——他们似乎直接就扣了，但他们不给我发发票。他们不给我发收据。然后我就想：“我该怎么跟我的会计师交待这件事？我该去哪里找凭证？”对，不，它在某些方面有点像个秘密社团，你可能每隔很久才会收到一封电子邮件，但与他们没有太多交流。我想这就是为什么我一直留在 BPS，因为……我想我当时觉得……嗯，我告诉你，当我在芬兰度过那大约五年的时间时，芬兰的对应机构——那个心理学学会——真的变成了一个地方，你知道，它几乎就像一个家庭。
I lived in a small place and I was invited to go to their meetings and then I became part active part of them and also when I was then trying to get my qualifications kind of transferred over and what have you and I was even in you know contact with their president and all of that and he was helping me so it became such a community and I felt like you know this is like exactly what you need in your life professionally not obviously the BPS is not quite the same you know much bigger organization and and so on but I felt that I needed to belong somewhere because otherwise you know especially now working in private practice not part of a bigger organization And the HCPC is just somewhere there really far, you know, in the background. And it feels like there's no connection to that at all.
我住在一个小地方，我被邀请去参加他们的会议，然后我成为了他们积极的一部分。而且当我后来试图将我的资格认证进行转换等等时，我甚至与他们的主席取得了联系（你知道的），他一直在帮我，所以它变成了一个如此紧密的社团，我觉得这正是我在职业生涯中所需要的东西——当然 BPS 并不是完全一样，它是一个大得多的组织等等——但我感到我需要属于某个地方，否则（尤其是在现在从事私人执业、不属于更大组织的情况下）HCPC 只是在某个非常遥远（你知道的）背景中存在着。感觉跟它完全没有任何联系。
And that's why I really, you know, to be honest, I wanted to stay with the BPS because I thought that, well, at least there's someone who will recognize that my qualifications and or you know if something happened hopefully i could turn to them for advice yeah i agree hcpc take the money and if there's any problems with our professional registration or someone complains about anything we're doing or or some of our colleagues are doing then they're there for that regard um but there's not much going on other than that and so it's yeah I think it's especially when you're in private practice it's about feeling like you're part of a club or something you know there's other people that get you and that's what I really like about our qualified group as well um but also I know that people listening to this will really value that support from from their peers as aspiring psychologists as well.
老实说，这就是为什么我真的很想留在 BPS，因为我觉得，至少还有人会认可我的资格，或者……你知道，如果发生了什么事，我希望可以向他们寻求建议。是的，我同意。HCPC 只是收钱，如果我们的专业注册有任何问题，或者有人投诉我们的所作所为、或者投诉我们某些同行的所作所为，他们在那种情况下会出现；但除此之外没有太多进展，所以……是的，我觉得尤其是当你从事私人执业时，这关乎一种加入某个俱乐部或类似组织的感觉，你知道，有其他人懂你。这也是我真的很喜欢我们的合资格群体的地方……但我也知道，听这个节目的听众也会非常珍视来自同伴的支持，作为有志心理学家也是如此。
It's about finding your tribe, isn't it? And feeling not so vulnerable in any of the positions we're in. Absolutely. Absolutely. It's really important. And that's why the psychology network, the online network has been so important because over the years I mean you've probably been there more or less from the beginning of a certain website Facebook group being being there and it's just you wanted to know that there's someone who you can go to and ask I mean yes you've got your supervisors but it's not the same you don't get the same instant you know response whereas if you post a question whatever it is you'll get you're likely to get some sort of answer within minutes almost and um and different perspectives as well because of course in the supervisory role it's you know it's just one person potentially um and there might be different views from and different knowledge obviously that
这关乎找到你的社群，对吧？并且在我们的任何岗位上都不会感到那么脆弱。绝对的，绝对的。这真的很重要。这就是为什么心理学网络——在线网络——一直如此重要，因为这些年来，我的意思是，你可能或多或少从某个网站、Facebook 群组刚开始就在那里了，你只是想知道有这样一个人，你可以去找他问问题——当然，你有督导，但这不一样，你得不到那种即时回应，而如果你在上面发帖问问题，无论是什么问题，你很可能会在几分钟内得到某种答案，并且由于在督导角色中可能只有一个人，而不同的观点以及显然不同的人所分享的不同知识会让情况有所不同，所以有不同的视角也很重要，所以……是的，这真的很重要。
different people share so yeah it's really important yeah and i think we were just talking because we've got um similar professional um clinical interests in kind of trauma and stuff and we were just thinking together about the i guess the impact of precarious trauma, weren't we, on us as individuals, on us as parents, on us as partners, on us as friends. And, you know, we're recording this at the time where there's been some horrendous atrocities in Israel over the weekend and it's really a very moving time for so many people either because of their friends and family connections or just because of the things they've been witnessing and we were talking about yeah how we kind of draw limits around our incredibly empathic hearts really so that we don't burn out what how do you do that for yourself
是的，我想我们刚刚在聊，因为我们有相似的专业临床兴趣，比如创伤等等，我们刚刚一起思考了……我猜是关于继发性创伤（precarious trauma）对我们作为个体、作为父母、作为伴侣、作为朋友的影响，对吧？而且，我们录制这期节目的时候，正值周末以色列发生了一些骇人听闻的暴行，对于许多人来说，这是一个非常触动心灵的时刻，无论是由于他们的朋友和家人关系，还是仅仅因为他们目睹的事情。我们在谈论我们如何在我们极其富有同情心的内心周围设立界限，这样我们就不会筋疲力尽。你是如何为自己做到这一点的？
well i i think this has become even more and more important i think um over you know in my career like i was mentioned earlier on that i've entered a phase in life where i have small kids i had them quite late but also i'm in perimenopause which I know now that hormonal changes will impact also I mean I have been a highly sensitive person in the past but on top of that is the hormonal changes I think just more kind of feel things so I've had to draw limits to the amount of information I consume. Whereas maybe before I would watch the news a lot, but I've had to really limit it and knowing where to go
嗯，我……我认为这变得越来越重要，我认为……在我的职业生涯中，就像我刚才提到的，我进入了人生的一个阶段，我有小孩子，我生他们比较晚，而且我也处于围绝经期（perimenopause），我现在知道荷尔蒙的变化也会产生影响。我的意思是，我过去是一个高度敏感的人，但除此之外还有荷尔蒙的变化，我觉得事情变得更加敏感了，所以我不得不限制我消费的信息量。以前我可能会看很多新闻，但我现在真的必须限制它，知道该去哪里看，
and really limiting the number of clients you can see. Because when you're talking about trauma, you just can't be doing it to, I don't know how many you know like six six clients a day or something like that I mean I think at the minute my ideal number probably would be like two clients a day or something like that you know because if I see four clients even in the day I notice in the evening that I'm super tired and then it's a lot more difficult to be with the family even and they kind of whatever the kids you know squabbles and so on yeah it's in the limits are really important but also looking after myself in other ways in in really lifestyle it has to sort of
并且真正限制你可以接待的客户数量。因为当你谈论创伤时，你不能……我不知道你怎么做……比如一天接待六个客户左右。我的意思是，我觉得目前我理想的数字可能是一天两个客户左右，你知道，因为如果我一天看四个客户，我到了晚上就会注意到我超级累，然后要和家人相处就会困难得多，无论孩子们怎么争吵等等……是的，设立界限真的很重要，但也要通过其他方式照顾好自己，在生活方式上……它必须能够支持这一切，这比我在三十出头时所能想象的要重要得多。我想这就是多年来主要从事创伤工作的结果。这很艰难。所以我真的需要有这些边界并照顾好自己，而且治疗师往往不是那些记得首先照顾自己的人，所以它需要……你需要把这种理念灌输到你自己的脑子里，即“我需要先照顾好我自己，然后我才能做这份工作并为其他人服务”。绝对的。
support everything and it's much more important that in in my early 30s I would have ever imagined. And I suppose it's years of really doing just mostly trauma work. It's tough going. So I really need to have those boundaries and look after myself and it's not always a therapist often are not the the people who remember to look after themselves first so it needs to be like you need to be kind of drumming into your own head that you know I need to look after me first so that then I can do this work and be of service to other people absolutely I. I think it's really tricky, isn't it? Because you and I are obviously a sort of established stage of our career
我认为这真的很棘手，对吧？因为你和我显然都处于职业生涯的某个既定阶段，而且我们都在独立工作。所以我们可以围绕自己设计每天的日程，以确保我们不会筋疲力尽，无论是在同理心方面还是在心理健康方面。但对于我们的许多听众来说，你知道，他们身处节奏非常快、人手不足、超负荷服务的机构中，他们不得不一天做很多很多次会谈，可能并非所有会谈都具有巨大的创伤性，但我依然……你知道，还记得我在 NHS（英国国家医疗服务体系）工作时，我不得不看……或者说选择看……就我的工作而言，一天看五个客户……你知道，那是七个半小时的工作日，包括午餐休息，这确实很多。我知道听这个节目的听众会感到非常疲惫，而且压力过大。我们做的工作是如此棘手，而且我认为我们并不总是……或者人们没有意识到这是一项多么困难的工作：在那个时间里，你承载着别人的痛苦，你的神经系统在帮助他们调节，所以你不仅仅是一个……几乎像是一个冷漠的人——至少，你知道，我觉得我的客户可能从我这里得到了比我生活中任何其他人更多、持续时间更长的专注时间。因为总是会有其他干扰等等。但当我与客户在一起时，我是超级专注的。
and we're both working independently. And so we kind of can design our days around ourselves and to make sure we're not going to burn out, you know, either in terms of empathy or in terms of our mental health. But for many of our listeners, you know know they are in really high-paced you know understaffed over subscribed services where they are having to do many many sessions a day and possibly not all massively traumatic but I still you know remember when I was in the NHS I was having to see um or forward slash choosing to see in terms of my job five clients a day um you know what is
而且我也有点多动症（ADHD）大脑。所以我需要保持专注。这就是为什么……而且我可以处于那个空间里，因为除了我和客户之外什么都没有。但是，是的，它真的会变得消耗精力。是的，照顾好自己真的很重要。你说得太对了。你知道，即使我会花 50 分钟的专注注意力在我的一个孩子或我丈夫身上，他们也会想：“发生什么事了？”这很难。我确实试着在一天结束时留出五分钟，与我的两个孩子每个人都有专注相处的时间，但当你结束忙碌的一天、也许我们的耐受窗口（window of tolerance）变得更紧绷、你只想冲向终点线好坐着不被任何人需要时，这真的很艰难。这是一个微妙的平衡，绝对的，绝对的，是的，确实如此。我也这样做。睡觉时间在某些方面是我最喜欢的时间，只要每个人都安静地躺在床上，然后我们可以……我给小一点的孩子读书，然后对于大一点的孩子，我通常会去陪他，他希望我在他看书的时候陪着他，所以我会在他旁边读我自己的书，但这就好像我们在彼此陪伴，但这里面有些关于身体调节的东西，我们在“存在”而不是仅仅一起“做事”，当然还要试着
it seven a half hour day including a lunch break that's it is a lot and I know people listening to this will be feeling really strung out you know and really overstretched it's such a tricky job that we do and I think we don't always or it's not appreciated what a difficult you're taking someone else you are living someone else's pain for that time and your nervous system you're helping them to regulate so you're not just there as a kind of like almost like detached person at least you know I feel that my clients probably get a lot more focus time from me for much longer time than anyone else in my life. Because there's always other distractions and what have you. But when I'm with a client, I'm super focused.
抓住那些时刻，在一天当中（比如早上或晚上）花几分钟进行一对一的关注，但是……是的，除此之外，你知道的，和客户在一起时，那是属于他们的时间。它是如此专注。谢谢。我喜欢这个主意。所以我们的孩子年龄相仿，我们最近转变为给小一点的孩子讲故事，然后让大一点的孩子稍微晚一点睡觉，但他的房间里仍然保持安静的时间。
And I also do have a bit of an ADHD brain. So I need to be focused. And that's why, like, and I can be in that space because it is nothing else apart from me and the client. But it's, yeah, it can be really, it can become draining. And yeah, it's really important to look after oneself. You're so right. You know, the idea that I would even spend 50 minutes of focused attention on one of my children or my husband you know they would
但我喜欢这种实际依偎在一起、在一种宜人的安静中一起阅读的想法。我也许会看看我是否能引入这种做法——我们确实尝试留出受保护的时间，聊聊我们一天中最喜欢和最不喜欢的部分，但我其实很喜欢阅读，所以……是的，我通常只是在睡觉前这样做，但我喜欢这个主意，谢谢你，这个想法会在我的大脑中发酵，并希望也能渗透到我对待孩子的实践中——实践，你知道的，感觉好像在其他时候也在实践，对吧？是的，是的，绝对的，不，这……我的意思是，这是他主动提出的，他一直在要求这样做，然后我们经历了不同的阶段，但我认为……仅仅是那种一对一的时间本身就很重要，因为他们在上学期间以及其他时间并没有那么多这样的时间，所以是晚上，我想这也是为睡眠时的分离做准备等等，只是那种彼此陪伴，但彼此陪伴并不总是意味着你必须通过言语进行交流。它也可以意味着只是存在着、陪伴着，甚至身体有所触碰。谢谢你。当你说话的时候，我在想芬兰文化，真的。除了芬兰，我真的什么都不知道。
be like what's going on it's hard I do try to build in five minutes at the end of the day to have focused time with each one of my two children but it is hard when you are at the end of a busy day and perhaps our window of tolerance is more squeezed and you're just like ready to race to the finish line so you could just sit and not be needed by anyone it's it's a tricky balance absolutely absolutely yeah exactly I do the same the bedtime is in some ways my favorite time as long as everyone's quiet and in bed and then we can have a you know I read to my younger one and then my older one I usually go and and he wants me to be with him whilst he reads so I read my own book next to him but it's like we have together but there's something about the kind of bodily you know regulation and we are um being instead of just doing together um and obviously trying
除了我曾和一个芬兰人一起上大学，他有一件非常非常了不起的羽绒服，因为他告诉我芬兰非常非常冷，除此之外我觉得我什么都不知道。你能否带我们了解一下关于“身为芬兰人对你意味着什么”的一小段简短历史？好的，嗯，我想我脑海中浮现的第一件事是大自然，以一种完全不同的方式与大自然连接。如果你现在住在一个国家，你知道，那可能是你的生活方式。但它基本上是千湖之国，有那么多的湖泊。大自然简直就在你的家门口。英国人谈论天气等等谈论得很多，
to catch up moments and and kind of few minutes of sort of one-to-one attention throughout the or during the day maybe in the morning or in the evening but um yeah otherwise it's you know with with the client it's that time they are with you. It's so focused. Thank you. I love that idea. So we've got children that are a similar age and we have recently switched to sort of doing stories with the younger one and then giving the older one a slightly later bedtime, but still quiet time in his room.
但我认为在芬兰，你对大自然变化的关注甚至更多。所以显然有四个季节，你会经历真正真正的冬天。春天和夏天则有所不同，有时会像这里一样热，有时则不然，所以你知道，会有所变化，秋天显然也是；然后我想有一件事是关于阳光的，在冬天阳光很少，而在夏天阳光又是如此充足，以至于……你知道，你上床睡觉，甚至在……比如凌晨两点，感觉就像是白天一样，所以……你知道的，大自然真是太神奇了。就文化而言，我认为文化在很大程度上反映了这一点，而离开之后更容易反思身处其中的文化。第二次世界大战绝对是其中之一，还有战争时期，我们曾一度是俄罗斯的一部分，然后是瑞典的一部分，然后俄罗斯试图接管（你知道的），有……所有这些……你知道，许多许多许多……我们现在已经独立了一百多年（你知道的，超过一百年），所以……所有这些，我认为有很多创伤，例如我的同龄人、我的父母，当然还有祖父母所经历的……我的家乡是军队的总部，你知道，在第二次世界大战期间。所以我小时候听过很多关于发生过的各种事情的故事。所以我想有很多那样的经历。这在文化中绝对留下了伤痕，现在很高兴看到
But I love the idea of actually just snuggling down and reading together in sort of companionable silence I might well see if I can introduce that so we do try and have sort of protected time where we'll chat about the favorite part and least favorite parts of our days but I love I love reading actually so I yeah I do usually just do that before I go to sleep but yeah I like that idea so thank you that will that will percolate through my brain and hopefully trickle through to my practice as well with my children practice you know it feels like practice some other time doesn't it yeah yeah yeah absolutely no it's yeah it's it's I mean he initiated and he's been asking for it and then we're going through different phases but I think
年轻一代（因为这显然需要几代人才能走出来，希望如此），那些二十多岁的人……至少我们有互惠生（au pairs）和年轻女性等等，我认为他们似乎有着不同的活力，可能当你二十岁的时候，你无论如何都拥有与四十多岁时不同的活力……所以这里有很多历史上的创伤，并且……我认为关于……我的意思是，许多这样的研究或这种幸福感测量等等，他们把芬兰评得很高，但一个芬兰人永远不会说“我太幸福了”，因为我认为这来自于你生活中的那种满足感，我们拥有非常庞大的中产阶级，所以我们没有
there is something about just that one-on-one time because they don't get that much time whilst they're in school and and so on so it's the evening and I suppose preparation for the the separation when you're asleep and and so on and just kind of being there together but being together doesn't always mean that you're communicating through um you know, with your words. It can mean just existing and being and your body is touching even. Thank you. And as you spoke, I was wondering about Finnish culture, really. I really don't know anything at all apart from Finland.
很多处于最顶层的人，它不是那么等级森严的。而且……福利国家把人们照顾得很好。人们当然总是抱怨，因为……没有什么事是完美的。所以确实有这些。所以这是一个相当富裕的社会，一个小社会，因为只有 550 万、540 万人，所以，你知道，比伦敦的人口还要少。你可以想象，当人口这么少时，管理起来要容易得多……学校很好，或者医疗保健、所有这些事情，但是……我认为一般来说，人们过去的性格是：你必须相当谦逊，不要把自己抬得太高，所以……你知道，我在私人执业中所做的所有营销，我不得不做很多工作（你知道的），在展现自己和
Apart from I went to university with someone who was Finnish and had a very very marvellous feather coat because he told me it was very very cold in Finland but other than that I think I don't know anything would you be able to guide us through just a little tiny potted history about what it means to you to be Finnish? Okay well I guess the first thing that comes to my mind is the nature, the connecting with nature in a completely different way. If you live in a country now and, you know, that might be your life kind of thing. But it's basically the country of thousands of lakes, like so many. And the nature is literally on your doorstep. And whilst British people talk a lot about the weather and so on,
表现自己方面，这意味着什么，因为你本来不应该这么做……是的，我认为大自然，然后……亲近大自然真的很重要。非常感谢你为我们阐明了一点芬兰文化，因为，你知道，这不是我们许多人可能了解太多的事情。所以，是的，谢谢你与我们分享这些见解。听起来那真是一个长大的好地方。但正如你所说，比英国小得多。是的。哦，我绝不能忘记的是，圣诞老人住在拉普兰（Lapland），拉普兰显然是……你知道，拉普兰横跨四个国家，但其中很大一部分在芬兰，所以我得为他们做点宣传。太棒了，所以……是的，我们现在正在脑海中构想那里有时会变得多么寒冷和多雪。好的，谢谢你。现在你有一个相当独特的细分领域，对吧？你从事的工作……我最初考虑联系你参加播客，是因为有一天我做了一个搞笑的模因（meme），想到当我们作为心理学家去约会时……你知道，你会开始想到马斯洛的需求层次理论，你知道，那是一个开玩笑的帖子，但它确实让我想到了你和你的工作，以及我们如何为自己挑选一个“足够好/极其优秀”的伴侣。你能跟我们讲讲你的细分领域吗，玛丽？是的，我谈到了我的创伤工作，实际上我有两项业务，我把它们分开了。我把它们分开的原因是，我有那些
but I think in Finland you pay even more attention to the changes in the nature. And so obviously four seasons, you get proper, proper winters. The spring and the summer, it varies, can be a little bit like here sometimes it's hot sometimes it's not so you know varies and autumn obviously um and then I guess one thing that is about the the sun that in uh in the winter there's less sun and then in the summer there's so much sun that the you know that just um yeah you you go to bed or or even at well say two o'clock in the morning it's like at daytime so um it's you know the nature is amazing in terms of the culture I think the culture has been reflected a lot on this and coming away is easier to reflect when you are in
带着创伤历史的客户，他们想要解决这些问题，无论是童年时期的被贬低还是忽视——母伤（mother wound）是我合作的许多心理治疗客户的关键词。但在那之后，我真的很想开始做一些……你知道的，更轻松、更有趣的事情。我热爱什么？我的意思是，我……你知道，我喜欢谈论关系，多年来与治疗客户的交流中，许多人处于那种状态，或者他们正在从有毒的关系中恢复，或者他们想遇见某人等等。我意识到，实际上，（你知道的）这里本身就有一个细分领域：约会——当你走出那种状态，当你更专注于教练工作时。所以，当我们思考如何去寻找一个兼容的人时，一切都始于内心的探索，就像其他任何事情一样，它始于内心的探索：了解自己，知道你是谁，知道你在生活和关系中真正想要什么，当然还要了解你的历史，你的依恋适应（attachment adaptation），并理解你在关系中需要什么，以及即使在约会时如何沟通这一点。所以它不像……
the culture. The Second World War definitely and the kind of war times and we were at one point, we were part of Russia and then we were part of Sweden and then Russia tried to take over, you know, and there was, you know, all of that sort of you know many many many we've been independent now for 100 and whatever you know um over 100 years um that so all of that i think there is a lot of trauma that our for example my generation my my parents and obviously grandparents went through the, you know, my hometown was the, what do you call it, headquarters for the army. So during the Second World War. So there's a lot of stories that I heard as a kid about, you know, all sorts of things going on. So I think there was a lot of that. And that has in the culture has definitely left scars and now it's nice to see
你知道，就像大多数人一样，我过去也这样做：你走出去，开始结识人们，然后祈祷一切顺利，祝你好运。而大多数时候，什么结果也没有。根据你的恋爱史——就你的早期关系以及你对自我和关系的了解而言，甚至包括你作为成人的后来关系——如果你没有意识到这种吸引力的拉力是什么，你可能会被某些特定的动态所吸引。
that the younger generation you know because it obviously takes a few generations to kind of come out hopefully you know the ones who are in their 20s and at least we've had you know au pairs and young women and what have you and and I think they seem to have a different energy probably when you're 20 anyway you've got different energy to to when you're 40s but uh so there's been a lot of that historical kind of trauma and um and i think kind of what's about i mean a lot of this sort of you know studies or or this kind of happiness measurements and so on they've rated Finland really high but a Finnish person would never say I'm so happy because I think it comes from this sort of contentment in your life on the of you know we have a very large middle middle class so we don't
即使你意识到了，你可能最终还是会落入复制你在早期关系中经历的相同动态的境地。所以一切都始于你。但随后你还需要解决那些阻碍你前进的事情，无论是在自信心还是在走出去结识人方面。如果你对某种类型的人有那种吸引力，你也需要解决这些问题。所以你需要……内心的对话，你需要意识到它，你需要滋养你身上那些在早期关系或童年关系中可能没有得到滋养的部分，所以自爱是这项工作的重要组成部分。只有当你带着一种“你在充实自己的杯子、你的重点是在你自己身上而不是在
have very many people who are right on the top and you know it's not as hierarchical that way. And the sort of, you know, the state looks after people well. People obviously complaining always because, you know, nothing's perfect. But so there is that. So there is quite a wealthy society, small society, because there's only 5.5 million, 5.4 million. So, you know, less than in London. and you can imagine when you've got so few people it's a lot easier to manage um schooling is good or you know like health care all of that kind of stuff and but it's I think generally what used to be that the nature of people is that you have to be quite humble don't put yourself up too much so you know all of the marketing that I've done in my private practice I've had to do a lot of work you know in terms of showing up and
别人身上来实现完整”的心态去约会时……因为经常发生的情况是，很多人遇到了某人——我的意思是，这就是我作为（你知道的）与伴侣合作或帮助个人处理关系问题时所学到的——通常会有那种希望、愿望和……你知道的，你要求对方来让你完整，你知道的，但事实上，你们是独立的个体，你需要学会真正滋养自己。只有当你的……当你能首先照顾好自己的需求时，你才能与其他人建立关系，然后你就可以……是的，彼此共同调节，但这并不是依赖性的。你的幸福不依赖于对方或他们的状态。
putting yourself forward and what does that mean and because you're not really supposed to yeah I think the nature then you know being close to nature is really important. Thank you so much for illuminating us a little bit on Finnish culture, because, you know, it's not something that many of us probably know that much about. So, yeah, thank you for sharing those insights with us. It sounds like a wonderful place to grow up, actually. But yeah, like you said, so much smaller than the UK. Yeah. Yeah. Oh, I must not forget is that Santa lives in Lapland which is obviously part of Lapland you know Lapland covers four countries but a big part of it is in Finland so I have to do a bit of advertising for them yeah amazing so yeah we're just now conjuring up exactly how cold and snowy
所以，当你从“我拥有足够”的心态去约会时，你也更有可能吸引到有同样想法的人。我非常赞同。我合作过的许多单身客户几乎都在寻找一个伴侣来修复自己，然后才开始他们的生活。这就好像：“不，不，不，不，不，我们真的必须致力于让你享受生活，在生活中找到快乐，认为自己是值得的、是一个值得花时间相处的人，而不是认为其他人会为你做到这一点。”因为那样的话——而且我认为这也是作为一个父母、在抚养孩子时非常重要的事情，你知道的，他们需要觉得自己是有价值的，而不仅仅是因为你（你知道的）付出了关注，他们就必须感恩……你知道，因为那真是一个雷区，对吧？绝对的，是的。作为父母，我认为（你知道的）做这种创伤工作，听到那么多
that becomes at times okay thank you and now you've got quite a unique niche haven't you um that you're working in and um I first considered reaching out to you for the podcast because of a hilarious meme that I'd put together one day thinking about how when we're dating as psychologists um you know you start to think about um Maslow's hierarchy of needs and you know it was a bit of a tongue-in-cheek post but it really did get me thinking about you and your work and how we go about choosing a good enough forward slash brilliant partner for ourselves could you tell us a bit about your niche Marie? Yeah so I've talked about my trauma work so actually I have two businesses which I've separated and why I've separated them is because I have those clients
关于人们真的没有得到足够关爱的故事——世上没有完美的父母，但当他们真的没有得到足够关爱时，总会有一种“我不够好，我需要某人来让我完整”的感觉。所以作为父母，在某种程度上感觉压力挺大的。但是，与此同时，我对许多成为父母的客户说过：“自我同情是你作为父母最大的工具。”因为没有完美的父母，我们都会犯错。但重要的是，你要对你自己好，承认你的错误，并修复关系，通过这种方式，你的孩子
who very much come with the trauma history and they want to work on that whether it's child denomination or neglect you know mother wound is the key word for a lot of the clients that I work with in terms of therapy but then I wanted to really start you know doing something as a little bit more you know lighter more fun and what do I love I mean I you know I love talking about relationships and even those you know over the years with therapy clients many who were in that place or whether it was that they were recovering from toxic relationships or they were wanting to meet someone or what have you. And I realized that actually, you know, there's a niche there in itself, dating, when you come out of that and when you're more focused on coaching so when we think about how to go about finding someone who is compatible but everything starts from within like in anything else it starts from within knowing oneself knowing who you truly are what you want in life in relationships and also knowing
也会学到如何在未来修复关系。多么重要的话语，你知道的，即使到现在，跟我丈夫结婚 11 年、在一起 14 年、当了 10 年父母之后，你知道，我仍然总是想：“天哪，我刚才做得不够好，我需要修复这个裂痕，因为这对我来说很重要，它为未来铺平了道路。”我认为，就我和丈夫的关系而言，有时我也需要提醒自己，他不是读心术士，他想象或希望自己是读心术士是不切实际的，如果我没有沟通我自己的需求，我就真的不能单方面感到失望。这真的是我过去 13、14 年来的学习点之一，我想。是的，我觉得很多女孩子尤其是长大后并没有真正表达她们的需求。
your history of course your attachment adaptation and understanding what it is that you need in a relationship and how to communicate that even when you are dating so it's not as simple as um you know like most people I used to do this too is that you you know you go out there and you start meeting people and then you hope for the best, fingers crossed. And most of the time, nothing kind of comes out of it. And depending on your relationship history in terms of your early relationships and what you learned about yourself and about relationships, and even your later relationships as an adult, you might be drawn to certain dynamics if you're not aware what the pull is.
你的历史，当然还有你的依恋、适应，以及理解你在一段关系中真正需要的是什么，以及如何在约会时进行沟通，所以这并不是那么简单，你知道的，就像大多数人以前也这样做过那样，你出去开始结识新的人，然后祈求最好的结果，祈祷一切顺利。而大多数时候，什么结果也没有。根据你在早期关系中的历史以及你对自我和关系的了解，甚至包括你成年后的后期关系，如果你没有意识到这种吸引力是什么，你可能会被某些动态关系所吸引。
And even if you're aware, you might still end up in the in the place where you're replicating the same dynamic you had in your early relationships. So everything starts from you. But then also you need to work through perhaps those things that are holding you back, whether in terms of confidence and going and meeting people. You need to work through also if you have those pulls towards certain type of people. So you need to kind of the internal dialogue. You need to be aware of it. And you need to nurture the parts of you that maybe didn't get nurtured in your earlier relationships or in your kind of childhood relationships and so self-love is a massive piece of this work and and only when you're dated from a place of that you're filling your own cup and you are kind of your focus is on you rather than
即使你意识到了，你最终也可能还是会落入那种重蹈覆辙的境地，重复你在早期关系中经历过的同一种关系模式。所以一切都始于你自己。但同时，你也需要克服那些阻碍你的事情，无论是关于自信还是去结识新朋友。如果你对某种类型的人有那种吸引力，你也需要去克服它。所以你需要进行内在对话。你需要意识到这一点。你需要滋养你身上那些在早期的关系或童年关系中可能没有得到滋养的部分，所以自爱这项工作中的巨大一部分，而且只有当你从那种能自我满足、把重心放在自己身上而不是
someone else you know um completing you because often what happens is that many people they meet someone and i mean this is what i learned as when i worked as uh you know with couples or or in helping individuals with their relationships that's often there is that hope and wish and kind of you know you're demanding the other to complete you you know that but in fact you are separate entities and you need to learn to really nurture yourself and only when you're sort of when you can look after your own needs first then you can go into a relationship with someone else then you can yes co-regulate each other, but it's not dependent. Your happiness is not dependent on the other or how they are.
依赖别人来完整你的心态去约会时，因为经常发生的情况是，许多人遇到某人——我的意思是，这是我在与伴侣工作或帮助个人处理关系时学到的——通常会有那种希望和愿望，甚至有点要求对方来完整你，但事实上你们是独立的个体，你需要学会真正地滋养自己，只有当你能够首先照顾好自己的需求，然后你才能与其他人建立关系，然后你们才可以互相共同调节，但这并不是依赖。你的幸福并不取决于另一个人或他们的表现。
So it's when you are dating from a place of I have enough, then you are also likely to attract someone who thinks in the same way. I really agree. And so many of the clients I work with who might be single are almost looking for a partner to fix themselves and then to start their lives. And it's like, no, no, no, no, no, we've really got to work on you enjoying your life, finding joy in your life, thinking that you are worthwhile and that you're a good person to spend time with rather than thinking that somebody else is going to do that for you because then and I think it's something that is really important as a parent as well raising children that you know they need to feel like they are worthy not just that they you know need to be grateful because you know so and so has paid them attention yeah um you know because it's such a minefield isn't it absolutely yeah as a parent I think you know doing this trauma work and and and hearing so many
所以，当你从“我拥有足够”的心态去约会时，你也更有可能吸引到有同样想法的人。我非常赞同。我合作过的许多单身客户几乎都在寻找一个伴侣来修复自己，然后才开始生活。这就好比，不，不，不，不，不，我们必须真正努力让你享受生活，在生活中找到乐趣，认为自己是有价值的、是一个值得陪伴的好人，而不是指望别人来为你做到这一点，因为这样——而且我认为作为父母在抚养孩子时这也是非常重要的一点，你知道的，他们需要觉得自己是有价值的，不仅仅是因为你需要心怀感激，因为某某人给了他们关注，你知道的，因为这简直是个雷区，不是吗？绝对是的，作为父母，我认为做这种创伤疗愈，并且听到这么多人
stories of people when they really didn't get enough you know they are no perfect parents but when they really didn't get enough and then there's always the the feeling like I'm not enough and I need someone to complete me. And then so being as a parent, it feels that there's quite a lot of pressure in some ways. But, you know, at the same time, I've said to many clients who become parents, it's like self-compassion is your biggest tool as a parent. Because there are no perfect parents and we all make mistakes. But what's important is that you're kind to yourself and you acknowledge your mistakes and you repair the relationship and that way also your child
讲述他们的故事，当他们真的没有得到足够的爱时——世上没有完美的父母——但当他们真的没有得到足够的爱，然后就会一直有一种“我不够好，我需要有人来完整我”的感觉。因此作为父母，在某种程度上会感到相当大的压力。但是，你知道，与此同时，我对许多成为父母的客户说过，自我同情是你作为父母的最大工具。因为没有完美的父母，我们都会犯错。但重要的是你要对善良对待自己，承认自己的错误并修复这段关系，通过这种方式，你的孩子
learns about repairing the relationship in the future such important words you know and still now even with my husband I've been married 11 years um together 14 and I've been a parent for 10 years you know I'm still always thinking gosh I didn't I didn't do that brilliantly I'm gonna need to repair this rupture because that's important to me and it it paves the way and I think in terms of my relationship with my husband I also sometimes need to remind myself that he's not a mind reader it's not acceptable to you know for him to imagine or hope that he will be one and I can't really just be disappointed ethically if I haven't communicated my own needs that's been one of my learning points over the last 13 14 years I think yeah I think many times girls especially have grown up not really expressing their needs.
也能在未来学会如何修复关系。真是至关重要的话语，你知道的，即使到现在，我和我丈夫——我们结婚11年了，在一起14年了，我当父母也10年了——我还是经常想，天哪，我刚才处理得不够好，我需要修复这个裂痕，因为这对我很重要，它为未来铺平了道路。我认为就我和我丈夫的关系而言，有时我也需要提醒自己，他不会读心术，他不应该也无法想象或希望自己会读心术，如果我没有表达自己的需求，我就不能单方面地感到失望。这算是我过去13、14年里学到的心得之一吧，我想是的，我觉得很多女孩子尤其是从小就没有真正学会表达自己的需求。
And and then there's always been this this kind of this fantasy of the partner who knows exactly what I'm thinking. And so many even male clients come and say, my wife, you know, says that I should know what she's thinking. So, well, I tried to I tried to study humans and I still can't I can't you know I don't know what anyone what's going on in anyone's mind that we need to learn to express and uh and for many people it is difficult but even going into dating situations is many times it's difficult to express oneself there and communicate what is it that I want in the relationship instead of just hoping that hopefully the other person wants the same and without these important conversations we don't know is it going in the right direction
而且——而且一直以来，人们都有这样一种幻想，觉得伴侣应该完全知道我在想什么。很多男客户也会跑来对我说，我妻子觉得我应该知道她在想什么。我说，我试着去研究人类，但我还是做不到——你知道的，我根本不知道任何人心里在想什么。我们必须学会表达自己。对许多人来说这并不容易，但在进入约会时，很多时候也很难表达自己，去沟通我在关系中到底想要什么，而不是仅仅希望对方也想要一样的东西。如果没有这些重要的对话，我们就不会知道，这段关系是否正朝着正确的方向发展。
or is it not going in the right direction and uh yeah absolutely it's it's so important and for women especially to communicate what we want and what we need because it's not clear and and i think men's men men's thinking the way they think is very much more straightforward in some ways so if it's not on the radar it's not on the radar so that's why it needs to be and you know many times men have said and I think my husband as well that you know you need to be you need to be clear I don't know unless you're clear then I can do whatever but um if it's not clear it's really tricky to navigate really important stuff and I know you've got a podcast as well that that talks through some of these I know you've got a podcast as well that
还是没有朝着正确的方向发展。是的，绝对是这样，这太重要了。尤其是对女性而言，我们要表达出自己想要什么、需要什么，因为这些并不是显而易见的。而且我认为男性的思维方式在某些方面要直白得多，如果不在他们的雷达范围内，他们就根本注意不到。所以这就是为什么我们需要表达出来。你知道，很多时候男士们都会说——我想我丈夫也是这样——你需要说清楚。除非你说清楚了，否则我怎么做都行，但如果没有说清楚，要处理这些非常重要的事情就会真的很棘手。我知道你也有一个播客，里面探讨了其中一些……我知道你也有一个播客，里面……
that talks through some of these issues could you tell us a bit about that yeah so it's called how to love successfully and it's focused on dating specifically well dating and kind of well-being you know it's it's not just about relationships I mean so when I started to focus on trauma, I came across a lot of somatic therapies and did some training and so on. So all of this body based stuff really spoke to me. And I want to bring a little bit of that to the podcast, too, because we are these physical beings. We we you know, I used to be certain just living in my head completely disconnected from my body and and I find that this is the case with a lot of people on the whole so really understanding not only our thoughts but really what goes on in the body and
探讨了其中一些问题，能跟我们多讲讲吗？好的，这个播客叫《如何成功恋爱》（How to Love Successfully），它专门专注于约会，嗯，约会和幸福感。你知道的，它不仅仅关乎恋爱关系。当开始关注创伤时，我接触到了很多躯体疗法，并接受了一些培训等等。所以所有这些基于身体的方法真的很触动我。我也想把其中的一部分带到播客中，因为我们都是有血有肉的实体。以前的我也是这样，整天活在自己的脑子里，完全和自己的身体断开连接。我发现很多人的总体情况也是如此：不仅要真正理解我们的想法，还要真正理解身体里发生了什么，
kind of making the connections whether you are dating in the relationships just living your life really you need to know what's going on in your body because of course your emotions live in your body so yeah so I invite guests and we talk about relationships from different angles but I also do individual or like solo episodes and talk about different dating dating kind of related topics and and so on where can people listen to the podcast if they'd like to take a listen so the easiest way perhaps is to find via my website so it's drmarie coveningcoaching.com forward slash podcast and then also i have a youtube channel which is called how to love successfully so you can find there too if you want to listen and watch on on youtube i'll give you all the links so you can put them in the show notes
并将它们联系起来，无论你是在约会、处于恋爱关系中，还是仅仅在过日子，你真的都需要了解你的身体里发生了什么，因为当然了，你的情绪就住在你的身体里。所以，是的，我会邀请嘉宾，从不同的角度探讨恋爱关系，但我也做个人单口节目，谈论不同与约会相关的话题等等。如果人们想听的话，可以在哪里收听这个播客？最简单的方法或许是通过我的网站找到它，网址是 drmariecoveningcoaching.com/podcast；另外我还有一个 YouTube 频道，叫做“如何成功恋爱”，如果你想在 YouTube 上收听和观看，也可以在那里找到。我会把所有的链接都给你，你可以把它们放在节目简介里。
yes i will indeed so before we finish could you offer our listeners, you know, your top tip for perhaps reducing burnout on the way to a career as being a psychologist would be marvellous. Oh, my goodness. This is a thing for all of us in different stages of our lives and and yes I do remember how it was then you know aspiring to be a psychologist and and maybe sometimes you know there was that sort of questioning whether will it ever happen and I guess it's sometimes it's about honoring well a lot of times it's about honoring our feelings and not trying to deny that but just mindfully observe and being with and noticing that and really having in life other things too. So I can understand that they work and if you are, as an assistant psychologist and whatever you're doing right now life is probably
好的，我一定会这么做的。所以在我们结束之前，你能不能给我们的听众们一些建议，比如在成为心理学家的路上如何减少职业倦怠？这真的很棒。哦，天哪。这是我们人生各个阶段都会面临的问题。是的，我还记得当时自己渴望成为心理学这一切时的情景，有时也会产生那种怀疑：这一切真的会发生吗？我想，有时候这关乎尊重——很多时候是关乎尊重我们的感受，而不是试图去否认它们，而是正念地观察、与它们共存、注意到它们，并在生活中拥有其他丰富的事物。我能理解他们的工作，如果你作为助理心理学家，或者无论你现在在做什么，生活可能都
very busy and like you were mentioning earlier on that you know work in the nhs and all of that kind of stuff but really focusing on having fun things outside there is life beyond the the work life and life is you know i notice it myself now being middle-aged that it goes so fast and if you just focus on career like I did for many years I feel so it's about kind of grabbing those small moments and trying to be in the moment but also you know acknowledging if you're having a difficult time and it's difficult to trust whether you'll get to this career that you want to do there's always a way there's always I mean I think that's what I've learned in life is that whatever even if it's not the path that I initially thought there's maybe a round trip that can help me to get where I need
非常忙碌，就像你刚才提到的，在 NHS 工作以及诸如此类的事情。但一定要专注于在工作之外寻找有趣的事情，工作之外还有生活。我发现，现在人到中年，自己也注意到了，时间过得太快了。如果你只专注于职业生涯，就像我多年来做的那样，我觉得……所以这关乎抓住那些微小的瞬间，试着活在当下，同时也要承认，如果你正经历一段艰难的时期，很难去相信自己是否能达成想要的职业目标，生活总会有出路的。我的意思是，这就是我在生活中学到的：无论如何，即使它不是我最初设想的那条路径，也许也会有一段迂回的旅程，能帮助我到达我需要
to go so that's what I would say really. love that. I've not heard that before either. So it might not be the path, but it might be like, you know, a looping road that helps you learn something that's useful for your actual journey. Yeah. Oh, I love that. That's made my day. I will use that with clients in the future. So, yeah, we've got your website and that will be in the show notes and we've got your YouTube channel that will be in the show notes. You're also on LinkedIn and on Instagram. So I know we discussed beforehand that you're Dr. Mari Covenant on LinkedIn and you are Dr. Mari Covenant Coaching on Instagram.
去的地方。所以我真的会这么说。太棒了。我以前也没听过这种说法。所以它可能不是那条直路，但它可能就像是一条盘旋的道路，帮你学到对你实际的旅程有用的东西。太棒了。这让我今天心情大好。以后我也会对客户们说这句话。所以，是的，我们有你的网站，它会放在节目简介里，我们还有你的 YouTube 频道，也会放在节目简介里。你也在领英（LinkedIn）和 Instagram 上。我记得我们之前讨论过，你在领英上叫 Dr. Mari Covenant，在 Instagram 上叫 Dr. Mari Covenant Coaching。
That's right. Yeah. Brilliant. Thank you so much for your time and helping us learn about so many important topics. You know know occupational psychology a bit about counselling psychology a bit about Finnish culture of course yourself and your very interesting niche as a dating coach. Oh thank you so much it's been such a fun conversation and it's all it's been so lovely also to speak with you really now in person, because, you know, it's almost like you watch someone's videos for a long time.
没错。太棒了，非常感谢你抽出时间，帮助我们了解这么多重要的主题：职业心理学、一点点咨询心理学、一点点芬兰文化，当然还有你自己以及你作为约会教练这个非常有趣的细分领域。哦，非常感谢，这是一次非常有趣的对话。能够真正面对面地和你交流也感觉太美妙了，因为你知道的，这就好像你看了很久某个人的视频一样，
It's almost like you get to know them, but you don't really know them and you haven't exchanged, you know, or had had a conversation. But, yeah, it's been really lovely to connect with you today and share something to your audience. Thank you so much. it's been such a pleasure and please let me know if i can help with anything in future oh thank you so much it's been really lovely oh what an absolute pleasure to speak to dr marie covenan i hope you found our conversation nourishing and wholesome and that it's given you lots of interesting points to reflect upon. Please do come and let me know what you think to the episode, which you can do by coming along to the Aspiring Psychologist Community free Facebook group. My next live compassionate Q&A date is on Tuesday the 7th of November at 6pm and that will be running across all of my socials
感觉就像你很了解他们，但其实你并不真正了解他们，你们也没有交流过或者进行过对话。不过，真的很高兴今天能与你连线，并为你的听众分享一些内容。非常感谢，这真的是一件很愉快的事。如果有以后有任何我能帮上忙的地方，请随时告诉我。哦，非常感谢，这真的太棒了。能与玛丽·科文南（Marie Covenan）博士对话真是一大乐事。希望你觉得我们今天的对话充满营养、积极向上，并且带给你许多值得深思的要点。请一定要来告诉我你对本期节目的看法，你可以通过加入“有抱负的心理学家社区”（Aspiring Psychologist Community）免费脸书（Facebook）群组来实现。我下一次直播富有同情心的问答日期是 11 月 7 日星期二下午 6 点，这将在我的所有社交媒体平台上同步进行，
so that's where you can catch the live one but don't forget those replay ones are available on my YouTube channel too the easiest way to do that is to go to Dr Marianne Trent click on the live tab and then you should be able to see them there but you can also look at the playlist which you can access by clicking any of the links in my social media bios and of course do consider the aspiring psychologist collective book and the clinical psychologist collective book thank you so much for being part of my world please do let me know what you think to this episode. And yeah, thank you so much for being part of my world. I will look forward to coming along with the next episode of the podcast from 6am on Monday. Take care, be kind to yourselves, and I'll see you very soon. With this podcast I feel sad, you'll be on your way to being qualified.
这就是你可以观看直播的地方，但别忘了回放也可以在我的 YouTube 频道上找到。最简单的方法是访问 Dr. Marianne Trent，点击“直播”标签页，然后你应该就能在那里看到它们了。不过你也可以查看播放列表，只需点击我社交媒体个人简介中的任何链接即可访问。当然，也请考虑阅读《有抱负的心理学家集锦》（The Aspiring Psychologist Collective book）和《临床心理学家集锦》（The Clinical Psychologist Collective book）。非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分，请务必让我知道你对本期节目的看法。还有，非常感谢你成为我世界的一部分。我期待在周一早上 6 点播客的下一期节目中与大家见面。保重，对彼此好一点，我们很快就会再见。有了这个播客，我觉得离获得资格又近了一步。
It's the Aspiring Psychologist Podcast. With Dr. Marianne Trent. My name's Jana and I'm a trainee psychological wellbeing practitioner. I read the Clinical Psychologist Collective book. I found it really interesting about all the different stories and how people got to become a clinical psychologist. It just amazed me how many different routes there are to get there and there's no perfect way to become one and this kind of filled me with confidence that no I'm not doing it wrong and put less pressure on myself so if you're feeling a bit uneasy about becoming a clinical psychologist I definitely recommend this just to put yourself at ease and everything will will be okay but trust me you will not put the book down once you start There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这里是《有抱负的心理学家播客》（The Aspiring Psychologist Podcast），我是主持人玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）。我叫亚娜（Jana），是一名见习心理健康从业者。我读了《临床心理学家集锦》这本书。我发现里面所有不同的故事以及人们如何成为临床心理学家的经历都非常有趣。到达那个目标有这么多不同的路线，这让我大为惊叹，而且成为一名临床心理学家并没有什么完美的方式。这给了我极大的信心，让我觉得“不，我没有做错”，从而减轻了对自己的压力。所以，如果你对成为一名临床心理学家感到有些不安，我绝对推荐这本书，它能让你安心，一切都会好起来的。相信我，只要你翻开这本书，就绝对不会想把它放下。本期节目暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。